boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we're gonna be talking about
vertical farming today and the
importance of Agriculture
State and we're gonna be featuring
Michael Barron what's up man hey how's
it going thanks for coming on to the
show really appreciate it you are your
plant scientist and R&D lead with arrow
farms for the last four years correct
awesome and all 2017 Forbes 30 under 30
Congrats thank you very much yes and you
did a master's in data science and
agronomy right two different ministers
what so masters in agronomy and then a
master's in data science after and I
actually had to look up what I Gras to
me meant because yeah I I you know you
think that you know agriculture and on
me okay science of Agriculture and then
that kind of made sense soil management
and crop production yeah that's super
important to know especially as we move
into this era of trying to make our
farming more efficient in crop
production more efficient so yeah you
guys have been working on this
incredible technology now and you're
actually selling vertical farm the leafy
greens now in stores in the Northeast us
which is freaking awesome Congrats yeah
so so tell us a bit about this journey
the last four years because like how the
hell do you even figure out you know
like let if we're like let's we'll
transition quickly to the technology
page on your website and just to show
the viewers like kind of like what like
what it looks like but this is so
interesting because you got you got you
know these are stacked that's why it's
vertical so that's stacked you know
leafy greens and there's no soil there's
no soil and there's no sunlight and what
they what you use that sunlight is you
use LED lights and then you also use
this cloth medium that has the seeds
that's
reusable and then you missed it with
water you missed it and that uses way
less water which is crazy and then you
have all these data that comes in and
pest management that's so interesting
and you're able to just yield just so
many amazing product so much amazing
product and we have some video to show
that too but I mean Michael go ahead and
give us your because I know it just took
you know years to get to so what was the
journey lichen and also just like tell
us some more about the technology it's
so fascinating sure so I joined aero
farms back in 2014 when I finished my
first master's and agronomy and I didn't
really know what to expect I'd never
been to Newark before and the first
place that I walked into was it used to
be a nightclub and a clothing store and
I walked in there's all this graffiti on
the walls and and it's a really surreal
experience to walk in and see our first
version of these our stack machines just
sitting there in the middle of an old
nightclub growing plants and you know I
guess for me the rest is history I was
sold dumped on just seeing it in place
and so the journey I think I was
employee number eight or something like
that at the time and now we've grown to
a company of 120
we've moved out of the nightclub and we
are in our our large production facility
and also in Newark but on the other side
of town in an area called the Ironbound
but yeah that's that's sort of a really
reversion of of my story there but the
technology itself is really I mean I
work with it every day and I still find
it fascinating so you explained it very
well what we do is we grow plants
aeroponically and so a lot of people
have heard of hydroponics where the
roots will grow in a water-based medium
and aeroponics takes it a step further
in terms of optimization
so instead of having the root suspended
in water they're actually suspended in
the air and we missed them with a
nutrient-rich mix
periodically so that they're getting the
optimum amount of water the up an amount
of nutrients throughout their growing
cycle as you mentioned we grow not in
soil not and on a different but on a
different substrate
it's a bpa-free cloth which is made of
recycled plastic post-consumer recycled
plastic and it's completely reusable so
we're able to put the seeds on that put
it into our systems the roots grow down
into the solution chamber they're misted
the plants grow they're provided with
light from the LEDs and yeah we were
able to produce more and a lot quicker
than a field farm
uh-huh okay I love how you said that
or you're so fast all the like that
and I like this step towards leveraging
more effective grow mediums and then now
the aeroponics is like a next step as
well and it makes sense because your are
you misting from the bottom then onto
the roots or are you missing from the
top because the LEDs coming from the top
right right LEDs from the top we're
Mystik missing from the bottom and
you're just and you just some spray onto
the root system every 10 minutes
something like that nautically yeah
depends on which crop but we have you
have tailored recipes for birds Oh
interesting
the tailored recipe so so you've been
able to like measure the success of
growing lettuce arugula kale and other
leafy greens and and your and you're
measuring the efficiency at which they
grow based on the amount of water and
LED that you're giving them light
exactly right oh my god so cool okay
whatever what have been some of these
interesting like discoveries like how
did you end up like tweaking it over
time to make it better
like what's the in like what's you know
the significance of making it all
vertical like vertical farming that's
the safe space and you know to be able
yeah yeah but like tell us more like is
it also more efficient for you know
water more efficient for lighting as
well and and yeah tell us about all
these great yeah yeah but yeah exactly
right to save more space because
traditional I mean horizon the land um
it takes up we aren't limited plane of
growth we cheap there are several levels
huh so if if the building is safe feet
tall we can fill up that entire with
different levels of growing so it's the
same
you know horizontals but we're able to
grow in orders of magnitude more crops
per square foot if that makes any square
foot of space exactly versus farmland
that is only one level now you're
growing multiple levels on above yeah
right and so when I started everything
has been in marching towards
optimization and and greater
efficiencies so we have actually knocked
a few days growing cycle and an amount
of growth cycles we year since I've been
there and we're still moving for
direction so yeah those have been huge
or as a typically takes about 30 to 45
mr. Grove beefy greens we do it and so
what's the normal what's the normal and
what did you guys get it down to sorry
yeah
so 30 to 45 days for field grown leafy
greens and we've got it down to two
weeks holy cow you haved it that is
crazy yeah and so we're also not limited
by external the external climate or our
inclement weather conditions since we
can deliver the exact environment of the
plants need and desire for their growth
we're able to grow you know much quicker
and so once one harvest is done what the
next growth period can begin so feel a
farm is limited to a season and there's
no indoors that's huge yeah now you can
now you can stuff and what we quick
question is what is the temperature that
you keep inside we it varies but we
control it to a set level
it's like like room room ish temperature
like seven the room is temperature yeah
without being able to give away any of
this
oils yeah yeah okay so room is temp so
then this so then this works cuz you can
grow this in the freezing cold
you know Greenland you can grow this in
the Sahara as long as you cool down the
or warm up depending on your environment
the warehouse space and then you can
grow fricken leafy greens all year long
that's that's so awesome
are there other like I want to ask you
about the data and software side of
things as well but are there other
plants that you're planning on growing
because two weeks I mean that's a quick
turnaround so like what else are you
considering sure we're considering a lot
of different crops there are you know if
I think we're starting with leafy greens
and we're looking to expect some variety
testing as well as interest from
outside sources looking into different
crops so we're considering and figuring
out what works what does what we should
proceed with
interesting
I wonder like isn't isn't rice like one
of the largest traded commodities and
you grow in the indoor farm rice mm-hmm
I don't know if we've tried rice in our
systems but actually Rises what I
studied for my micron head haha that's
so cool yeah so yeah I think it could
potentially be done a lot of development
agriculture will have to do with
breeding plants for specific
environments so rice rough typically and
purely across and there would have to be
something some genetic advance that
would allow it to grow in our types of
systems yeah it's not people entirely
it's just that we need other
technologies yeah I was just thinking
how would you need to tweak the arrow
farms
build out the tech stack to be able to
work with the different plants that need
that you'd want a vertically farm yeah
go ahead no you go okay I was gonna say
I think the core technology would remain
the same yeah just have to figure out
how to tailor it to support the
different structures for each kind of
plan so whereas greens you know it's you
get to harvest and eat the vegetative
structures there are fruiting structures
that crops or tomatoes or stuff like
that that we have going to tailoring the
system to support those kind of crops
but you know core technology certainly
remain the same yep then with the
software side of things in the data
science side of things the machine
learning like what are you guys learning
on that side because you know obviously
you brought down the crop grow time to
14 days so that means you definitely
figured out you know how often to spray
you know all this all this interesting
stuff so temperature control like like
the team's big now so obviously you're
you got a probably quite a bit of people
that understand how to optimize mm-hmm
yeah tell us about some of the things
you're learning that it that you can
teach us sure so we are looking at
several different variables all of our
like what basically what inputs
delivered when translate to a specific
set of outputs outputs being quality in
yield and so we have sensors throughout
the grow take different measurements be
it you know from environmental metric to
different gas met gas meters yeah we
also have nutrient solution that we're
monitoring and measuring so that we can
provide nutrient needed during the
growth cycle
that's a briefs different the different
variables that work but we're looking to
optimize for every variable give us the
the best highest product that we can
man is so interesting thinking about the
sensors for all the different uses that
you guys have in there I mean I'm just
so fascinated by thinking about it like
I want to come visit so bad
and RonRon we got a cool video that we
can play as well played it I've been
playing them throughout the show so
Ron's been playing them throughout the
show he's way ahead of me and he's
already been crushing it so that's good
that we got to show some of the video
because the like when you see the scale
the humans are like ants compared to
these vertical farms that go up so big
in it's really fascinating to be able
did we did we talk about where we can
now where you can buy the product well
that's what I'm about to show yeah let's
do that
so now we're gonna transition to your
dream Green's
page okay so now I'm on dream greens so
this is we went from arrow farms calm to
dream greens calm and so do you guys
I guess I got a quick brand question
first what was the reasoning behind like
not calling it the arrow farms like
greens but rather calling it the brain
greens sure there were definitely there
were focus groups run and dream on the
one out it's evocative green greens by
arrow you can also make different brand
lines after this one this is the one
that we've long yeah yeah yeah yeah
instead of like arrow farms lettuce
it's like dream greens lettuce buy arrow
farms yeah yeah yeah is I saw your
harvest and I'm sure that the the viewer
is also sought than in the video the
harvest looks crazy cool it looks like
you guys are automating really well but
like as you know as you scroll down here
you see that you guys have arugula
spring mix greens kale watercress so
this is packaged and available in stores
in the northeast of the US right now you
want to tell us how many stores which
outlets
so I actually don't know the exact
number of stores but the outlets are
we're selling and whole foods throughout
Jersey Whole Foods in New York City
several shop right in the same area and
then selling through Fresh Direct so a
lot of them word can can purchase our
greens okay to fill up two parts of
Connecticut I love your packaging by the
way it looks great I'm glad you guys are
in Whole Foods that's a huge player to
get into and near New York as well so
people in New York you'll East to go hit
them up definitely go try it out you
guys will have to ship us some to try we
would love to please do oh you had a
cool recipe I near rainbow harvest I'll
with quinoa and feta sounds so good I'm
sure like I'm excited cuz I'm gonna go
I'm gonna what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
go buy a bag of spinach and I'm gonna
have your spinach and then I'm gonna do
a blind taste test and I'm gonna try it
with I'm gonna try to the
producer/director and maybe another
couple people and we'll do this blind
taste test and we'll see if we can even
tell you know controlled study on you
know which one we think is is yummy and
delicious I'm excited
i I'm willing to bet be able to tell the
difference in taste yeah yeah I mean I
just I understand bias so obviously I'm
but the same type of something that sets
us apart from any other as our tastes
it's it's really quite remarkable each
of them has their own unique flavor
proof yeah and yeah it's it's not it's
not just a vehicle I actually don't use
Salinger I love to hear that I I'm one
of those weird guys that tries to not
eat salad dressing and I love it when I
don't because I get the full flavor
profile of the of and I usually add you
know tomato or onion or raisin or
whatever else to the mix also is this
direct-to-consumer can they buy online
yet we don't have that right yet but
through Fresh Direct they can they can
get it delivered ooh now I want to ask
you just a couple quick questions about
kind of the future like do you think
that we're gonna have vertical farms
like kind of like vertical farm
warehouse in in San Francisco and in LA
and in Seattle and Miami etc do you
think that we're gonna have these kind
of localized near the metropolitan areas
and then distributing to the cities and
same thing in Beijing and Singapore
etcetera across the world yeah that's
actually a huge part of our business so
most of the greens grown in Salinas
California are yuma arizona to connect
and to get to eat they have to be
shipped thousands of miles and reefer
trucks just the new york city market a
lot at the spoilage and you know it
affects the shelf life it affects the
getting to the consumer and so by being
a in newark few minutes away from new
york city we are able to deliver sure
malicious greens to market its idea is
to these farms next to every into or
next every major city
throughout the world might sound
grandiose but that is awesome I love
that I love that vision I'm glad you
guys have that similar vision it's a
tremendous amount of energy inefficiency
to have to ship it so far in trucks it's
not as fresh when he gets there he has a
higher chance of spoilage I guess as
we're on the topic of spoilage do you
know how long yours last compared to a
regular spinach grown in a bit put in a
bag in the store iris has a pretty long
shelf life I I'm not on the marketing
team they would know these numbers right
yeah
but ours I want our shelf life is 16
which is 16 yeah then days yeah damn
two-week shelf life err we have we we
had certain active liver almost a month
wow that's impressive
Wow yeah I really really love and what
your vision is with bringing vertical
agriculture and farming to the world
what our I guess you know we kind of
asked you a bit about this too I mean
this is gonna be huge for being able to
you know feed the world and do it more
effectively using less resources like
water and and even in areas that
sometimes don't get light like in the
north and this very north and southern
parts of the hemispheres they don't get
light during six months of the year so
that's also really interesting as those
people can't even grow the crops at that
time there's not sunlight yeah there's
so many cool solutions to this
yeah it's I mean it addresses a lot of
problems I kind of joke that it's my
undergrad was in environmental science
and then I have my masters and agronomy
and a master's in data science so the
only place I agrees can can work
together yeah yeah okay cool I think
that's that's pretty solid I want to ask
you maybe a couple questions on the way
out that you typically ask on the show
this is these are some you know some
kind of like
for the wool all this is running by the
first question is do you think we're do
you think we're alone in the cosmos hmm
I think it would be presumptuous to say
that just because we haven't identified
you know extraterrestrial life does it's
not there as a scientist and general
skeptic I'm waiting until we know but I
think I I think it's hard to say yes or
no either way so I think the search sort
of my non answer to that question
Michael do you think we live in a
simulation
hmm what do you mean by that do you
think that we live in a simulation that
there is this is not base reality that
we are being simulated hmm I've heard
I've heard certain things like that I
don't personally believe it again as a
generally a skeptic but I think I really
interests thought experiment to say that
this is just a simulation and it's under
what else what's what's the real yeah
yeah what what is the exactly what's
going on what is truth that's why that's
why it's so interesting because it's
trying to understand the truth and then
last question what do you think's the
most beautiful thing in the world hmm
most beautiful thing in the world this
is gonna be cliche but love tell us why
it's a I mean there's there's an
evocative feeling that comes with being
in love you know feeling it a trap
supported feeling welcomed feeling home
and I think that's when certainly I
people as well feel the happiness and I
think I think that's a positive thing
that everyone can relate to you so yeah
I'd say beautiful Oh awesome this was
such an educational episode on vertical
farming Michael Barron thanks for
joining us really appreciate it this was
great yeah and with what a future we
have ahead of us with figuring out how
to feed the world in a more sustainable
way yeah yeah you rock thanks to Aero
farms team huge thank you definitely go
check out the site we got links in the
bio we got a link to Michael's LinkedIn
as well you reach out to him also
definitely go and check out dream greens
go and get something from them go and
support them we'd love for that to
happen
check out aeroponics what a cool idea
what a cool system if you guys learn
something new go in there with two other
people don't just consume this content
go create with it make a video go write
about it also join us subscribe comment
below join the community start talking
about it
support us on patreon let's keep scaling
this so maybe we can take our equipment
and come to Aero farms and highlight all
the brilliance that show you directly
there we really were really excited to
do that soon much love everyone Michael
again huge thank you for joining us
thank you alright bye everyone
[Music]